Love Changes Everything it is the Andrew
Lloyd Webber 80s earworm that hung
around in the charts for 15 weeks back
in the day and introduced the world to
musical theater pin-up Michael Ball
[Music]
now over 30 years later He's Back
singing it again as aspects of Love
returns to the West End bracing himself
for yet more heckles in the street I get
Love Changes Everything Michael
does love change everything Michael oh
yeah yeah yeah and does it how how did
this oh my God change things
this show literally changed my life on
on every level it's a little more
problematic stage now with the original
production about the sexual Awakening of
a 15 year old to seem less predatory
ages have been tweaked and an emphasis
put on female empowerment it's weird
isn't it this is not something that was
was ever a feature in 1989 but now it
very much is and we have to be sensitive
to those issues and change the narrative
uh it's important what also wasn't
taught about then was mental health and
what isn't widely known is as his career
began so too did a period of anxiety
depression and panic attacks my first
Western show everything should have been
amazing and my world imploded and I made
the error of not talking about it not
getting help and it makes you vulnerable
and it makes you very aware that you
need to you need to be well thankfully
there was no need to feel nervous when
Lord Andrew Lloyd Webber came to watch
one of the musical's early previews he
came up with tears in his eyes put his
arms around me and just thanked me and
said this the only time I've felt this
was on the first preview of phantom it
was really special and so unlike it
Love Changes Everything but what would
love changes everything being quite a
fun one to sing along to are they
worried about audience participation
there will be murders they can't hit
that top note I hope it doesn't happen
because there is nothing more
distracting Behavior behave yourselves
you'll have a better night
theater fans
Casey Spencer Sky News